- The winner of Alone season 5:
Come on in, Sam.
Say hello to your buddy, Britt.
- Hey, Britt.
- Hey.
Good to see you, man.
Hug.
It's been a minute.
Yep.
You look good, man.
So what do you think?
Guys, you're buddies.
It's OK.
You know, we weren't sure.
We wanted to make sure
how the relationship
is here, with you guys
battling it out to the end.
It's actually pretty good.
Our wives are close.
Our families are planning
on getting closer.
I'd like to meet his kids.
He hasn't met my kids yet,
but our wives are buddies
and, you know, we actually
developed a relationship
throughout the course of this.
- That's really neat.
Well, we were talking about
family and motivation,
things like that, Sam, and--
similar, right?
Because you both are dads,
and you're both husbands.
I mean, you left when you
had a one week old at home.
You already had a 2
and 1/2 year old son.
Just how difficult was
that for you, with the pull
of family at home?
It was extremely difficult.
But when it came down to it,
I thought about them
when I was out there,
and honestly, I was
thinking, you know,
if I tap any minute now,
I'm going to go home,
and they're going to say,
we're so proud of you.
We're so happy that
you did what you did.
And that's the kind of people
you want to try hard for.
So that was my motivation
the entire time,
and I know that was a huge part
of why Britt did so incredibly
well this season, as well.
- Yeah.
There's no question about it.
Did you have any
idea that maybe--
it would be you two
down at the end?
Did you have any thought
process of who else
was out there when
you were there?
It's actually really weird,
because I was also thinking
about Britt the whole time.
And we had had some good
talks before the show,
and he just seemed so
motivated, and so ready
to take on the challenge that I
did actually expect it to be--
to be Britt, to a lot of--
you know, to a big extent.
So what would you say to
Sam, sitting next to him
right now, after this
whole experience?
I'd say he's a tough SOB.
Because I know how
hard it got out there,
I know how cold
it got out there,
and if anybody was
out there like,
suffering as much as I was, then
I gotta take my hat off to him.
He did a great job.
How about you to Britt?
Well, you always think,
like, who is this crazy person
who's out there with me still?
- Yep.
But proud of them, and I
think he did an awesome job.
And it was fun to watch.